My guest today is one of the funniest and most original of the new young comedians in a
few years he emerged from behind the scenes as a gag writer to the spotlight as a
star performer in the best clubs in the country. His first record has been
released in July. He is Mr Woody Allen.
Mr Allen. How did you land still in your twenty's in front of a Mike making people laugh.
Well when you say and still in my twenty's. That seems to be a customary age
to begin I would say that I'm a late beginner as a matter of fact most of the comedians that I
know were very interested in performing and going to see other comedians.
I've seen as far back as their teens and you know when they're eighteen or nineteen they were
already seeing things in the mountains and scuffing around for any kind of work
they could get before me I didn't start performing at all till two I guess I'm twenty six at
the time so you just knew this couple of years and I've been doing it about two and a half years. You know
what with the steps that led up to you being a performer because you weren't planning to be were you when you were younger.
No I was the furthest thing from my mind. Actually I started writing when I was very
I want to be a comedy writer and I start writing the piece on his radio show when I was about
seventeen in high school in
Brooklyn and that show led to the herb Shriner television show and
that show led to another and pretty soon I was working year after year
very consecutively from show to
show in television with absolutely no interest in performing I
was much too shy to perform and I was interested only in writing a play
or something of that nature in the movie maybe and about two and a
half years
ago. It occurred to me that I might want to try out
some funny things that occurred to me that wouldn't be right for a play they were too
small the ideas were too small for plays and there was no place
on television where I could really give them to other comedians and it occurred. We want
to just give it a try and see what would happen I couldn't care less if I succeeded I was
a dismal failure. Nothing didn't matter to me at
all and for the first six months of performing I losed it.
I really hated it because I was working at that
time on The Garry Moore Show was writing it making. A
tremendous salary writing
it and I had to go down in the evenings it was freezing at night and I
would do a hard day's work writing and go down in the evenings in the village for no money when I
say no money I mean no salary at all not a
dollar just they were doing me a favor letting me break in and I get up on the floor of a little club called
the duplex I'm going to village and I would try my act to six customers or
ten customers that never had any people
or and it was a brutal experience that went on that way until I got an
act going. How did you get over being shy. I still haven't really gotten over being
shy I'm still considerably shy really I
was Riddick I was so shy at that time that I was unable to get up on stage for years and
finally I got up in the most tentative manner really and I was ready to
quit every night it's just a painful
experience and then after a while. I found to my amazement that I was
getting exceptions from quarters that I respected
my
peers the comedians that I really like very much very
encouraging and the newspapers and magazines apparently found something because they gave me a
great
many good reviews very early and I got into a lot of major
magazines my first year
performing and I got a lot of television shots so you know I started to go that
Alb place in the perspective of other comedians we were influenced by
the group of young comedians of that or just had to be like Mort Sahl Lenny Breau.
Influence to the degree that I find them funny and you know
I not really influenced too much when I first
started. Well this is about as I said turn half years ago I thought that I leaned a little
bit toward Mort because I had tremendous respect for him
and I guess I even sounded a little like him I didn't work like him or
do what he did but the vocal intonation is almost the same
because you know I would go and see him all the time and just sit AUSTRAC he was you
know skyrocketing to fame at that time and dazzling
audiences and. So I was influenced to that degree but that didn't last very long when I first
thought of the one criticism in terms of their evasion from
people was that I reminded them slightly of Mort Sahl but I never get that anymore.
I just gradually drop that as I became more confident.
You know it's something you throw away the crutch that you're leaning on
and so it doesn't happen anymore
Fortunately he does a good deal of political satire and commentary. Are you interested in doing that.
I'm not interested in doing it that the own people have asked me why do you avoid politics I don't avoid them.
If something funny occurred to me that was political tomorrow on any political subject that
all I would do it is just that nothing as of yet has occurred to me.
That would really be worth doing you know that's political How do you get your ideas for jobs
what kind of things to manage. I don't know if you know it's a very
painful process of discouraging it and it's very hard to say
nothing. I couldn't begin to describe the process for you I walk along
the street in something funny occurs to me in the most
bizarre way I was walking along the street new card to me want to be
funny if there was some sort of little animal that was an animal when it walked on
four legs and you could certainly pick it up and play it like an accordion and it would make
music. Now I can't tell you how that thought originated or why it
suddenly hit me with that vivid
clarity all of a sudden you know nothing the sequence of thoughts led up to it and I made a little notation
on the inside of a match. And I have home. Dozens of matchbooks and little things
I've noted jokes labels and napkins and things and
I assemble them and you know improvise in my
room. Do you work out on a joke in which you get this idea and what do you do with it. Oh
yes I try
and actually eventually find a way of saying it where it's
really economical and pithy you know I like to be able to say
it
fast and most effectively. And while I vary
enormously in the general description of stories when it comes
to certain punch lines. I say them. I dentical you all the time really the
same beat the same you know if I for instance if out cough.
On a punch
line and it aids my timing and I did it
once cough. Every time I do that line and that's what America
just reflexively you know without putting on the coffee I'll come to that line and
my instinct for timing
will make me cough and I will and you know the lion will get its usual laugh
assuming that it didn't
originally projected you know can you say that over and over again. Does it get by rote I mean do you
lose the you move it
yourself I don't lose the you are of it but I but I do find from playing night after night
that I find myself up on stage and aimless Tuesday evening or
something and I'll be saying
my act and I'll notice that I will be going by rote for a minute and
then I stop myself and sort of relax and again lapse
into relating it in a
definite spontaneous conversational
manner but occasionally you do. Suddenly start
reciting and that's a bad habit to get into You've got to keep
alert you base a lot of your jokes on your family or mother or father or
grandfather do these people really exist as in any form the way they are Nischelle. Yes.
I would say I've been asked this constantly everything that I say
is very definitely based on truth. I
I do naturally have a mother and I did have that kind of relationship and to have
that kind of relationship with them exaggerated for comic purposes when I do it in joke form on
stage I was held up and robbed in my lobby I was married and divorced I am and it was
an analysis.
I was at the Hollywood California. I do have great difficulty with mechanical objects
almost unbearable. I was thrown out of New York
University and so all of that is true now of course.
I exaggerated. You know in relating it to an audience because you know otherwise it would be
pretty flat but it's true to that
extent I understood that you were thrown out of N.Y.U. and C.C.N.Y. in one year is
that right yes it was this on purpose. How does have they did it on purpose.
I don't know I was I guess a poor student and I went to New York University I was a motion
picture production major there because I can't think of anything else but they never went to class
and I never took tests. What textbooks or anything I showed up
and they threw me
out. You know. Do you regret not having on to some education don't you
care you know I really really don't regret it and not at all I
if they were out of tune with me completely.
You know I have no regrets whatsoever it would have been absolute waste of time in
certain areas. You see it is. Naturally there are some things for instance I wouldn't trust a doctor
who is not formally educated but. For a writer or a
comedian the need for formal education or formal education itself is a luxury I mean
I you know I read all that I want to and that's all I just I just would have
been of no value to me or such minimal value that to invest for years and it would have been just preposterous.
What kind of things you like to read.
Will for a few years there I read anything and everything. I
was always a great. Philosophy for my wife when I was
married was a philosophy major at Hunter College and I got a carious education
and philosophy through hardly just anything novels and and history and philosophy
and you know anything can lay my hands on and now slowed up my reading a lot in the
last two years or so because you know when I was thrown out of college. It was
a sensitive point with me because I
was an educated of course really
and there wouldn't be any education less educated myself so I would
just read. Day and night constantly and I read just everything I could lay my hands
on
really and that was it and then I admitted to myself after I had read the
philosophers and the psychologists in the his star in the novelists and
the
poets. That I don't like really you know I just like it that I did it
out of a sense of obligation every year or so. Every six months
I curl up with a book that I really get an emotional kick out of but it doesn't move me like
the theatre does there's just no comparison. What are the things you like
most I like some theatre.
I watch the Marx Brothers old movies and the slander you see feels old
movies and Leslie that excites me and a lot of things that Charlie Chaplin
did I like all kinds of music all kinds of classical music
and all kinds of jazz and. Gee I don't really know I like going
to theater a certain amount of the time there's just unfortunate not enough theater
around any real
value to see I like.
Walt Disney enormously and. Bergman the loneliest monk
I don't know it's hard to say really what I like.
I have very few. And very little time for recreation anymore.
How did you change effected your life of being no prominent entertainer is it a change for
the better or for the worse in terms. Way spend your time I think
it can really be only a change for the better in a sense no I'm
not talking economically it is obviously great
economically but it's a good emotional change I do find
it embarrassing to be recognized.
Genuinely embarrassing so much so that. I very very often don't go
into restaurants and I feel self-conscious when I go walking or something
because. The more you can television the more you get recognised and it just
embarrasses me that's all probably because secretly I have an urge to be recognised enormous
you know but it really does bother me
and yet still in oil. It is a sign
of success to be recognised so you have a mixed feeling about it.
On the whole although I
like succeeding as a comedian there's no doubt about
it I guess. Mostly because it opens doors for me I get more offers to write
things because of performing I get offers for. Projects that
I never would have been considered eligible
for are you thinking of writing in literary form or and for film. Yes and
a great many ways I think the writing I wrote a film I was paid to write a film and that came
about strictly through performing some people came into the Blue Angel in New
York and hired me to write a film and pay me a staggering amount of money I was just
absolutely stunned by it and it's a regular Hollywood film which I
wrote for Warren Beatty and
myself. It's not the kind of a film that I would choose to write
myself but I felt that I ought to do it because one because of the money
too because it would get my foot in the door in Hollywood both as a performer and as a writer.
So I did it purely as an investment to come out and have a come out yet it's going to be filmed in
Paris shortly. It's called like a new pussycat. And it's a sex farce.
And as I say it's not the kind of film that I would write myself but you
know it's a good enough for a start for an entree. I wouldn't do it again for double
the
money because I think if it didn't serve its purpose the first time in getting me
and then forget it but it was absolutely a good gamble and I am
writing a play for Broadway this fall a
comedy and I was asked since I've been performing oddly enough never when I was
a writer now than a performer. I've been asked
by several publishing companies to write books for them and I've been approached by newspaper
syndicate to write once a week syndicated hopefully
funny column you know sort of like Robert Benchley years ago that kind of thing that does interest
me I think at the time for now but it would interest me after a while I
think in your acts you often do a parody of a relationship or your wife or with other women.
What do you think about American women right now in the Senate and
mystique women. I found over the years that
they're different than men and they have to be evaluated by a completely
different set of standards
and there are certain aspects of them that's
enormously disappointing I find another aspect of them.
That's aesthetically super but I'm not talking about just physically Now there's.
There's an inscrutable.
Real
strange quality about them. That's absolutely fabulous in
its imperfection. They're not good to rely on they're
generally scatterbrain by nature the good ones are scatterbrain
and and generally worthless and so I have of course I have a particular
problem because I'm attracted
to I want the kind of woman that won't have me. That's the only kind
of interest me and I'm generally attracted to a
spoiled selfish
immature beautiful sadistic women because I will.
Yes because because I just am. That's all. So you're really getting a very biased
view
here and I find those women. Totally imperfect but absolutely lovely
and worth risking all for you know but.
I'm probably the world's worst person to ask
anything about women because my relationships with them are
really out of the
ordinary I have a psychoanalysis do you find that help coming to grips with
reality
particularly. It's some help. Yeah it's it's it's better
than nothing it's you know it hasn't been fantastic but it's better than nothing
I've been in the house just now about eight years and I've been
going four and five times a
week and I think that talking about yourself with
some objective person an hour a day five days a week for
years would be of some help regardless I mean just to take the time most people don't take the
time in their life ever to sit down and really try and make connections between their thoughts so just on a
purely non-medical level it is of some value automatically and with of course
a trainee
analyst it naturally is of much greater value
but it. I found it. I don't know to be honest. Maybe a little disappointing I
had hoped that I would come out of analysis as absolute
swordsman and spoiler of women and you know great uninhibited
with the type where the Western world and.
I haven't. And there's nothing I can do about it because I make no
promises when you get home. Don't know says if you for five days a week eight eight years
nobody is interested in you for an hour a
day you know is the point is he's not interested in hearing the whole idea of analysis.
No you know nothing that I
was free to leave at any time and certainly could leave it any time
and I know it's in no sense or wasn't for me in any sense.
Habit forming at all I just hoped that it would you know work
out and it was of some value
definitely who's to say where I could've been a performer or not. If it weren't
for now just now I might have just simply done the exact same thing if I wasn't masses.
I might not have but we'll never know
so well there's none of these things enter into your activity and analysts
or all the reading you've done this last thing in it's very direct personal
experience they do enter into my act
but not in the any sense because
I'm against that definitely I'm against what I want my activity I would like to
do as a stand up so-called stand up comedian one who talks to an audience.
I would like to get into my act to sing surrealistic insanity as the Marx
Brothers did in their movies in ratio. You know because I'm working in a different
media now facing an audience and talking to them the Marx brothers ran amok and a movie set
was a different
thing but as far as those things entering in they do enter in because I
do talk about analysis a great deal and to
approach certain subjects with I would say the stereotyped Freudian
conception of things and I
do jokes on philosophy I don't. For instance do
or piece of comedy material that's steeped in you
know existential thought that's not consciously you know you could bring that
to it. I mean to anybody if you wanted to but I mean I never would attempt anything like that
because it would bore me
stiff. Are there any things. What is it you like to criticize in American society we get so
many positive back and former the materialism you think about things
like this. Well I'm pro conformity and pro materialism think
those things. Generally interest me I want wealth. And
accumulation of
goods and all things like that you know there's I think good and
healthy and you know I I like that and I also like.
I don't. Well I can't say that I like to conform I like to do what I want to do really you
know but.
I don't want any big piece. Will stopping there you know if I like to give them anything that
they want or play their game. I'm not a. Like a courageous I don't
make citizen's arrests or anything like that. You know I like to play it fairly
safe with the rebels. No I can't do that I would be a rebel in any sense of
the word I just really want to be left alone to do exactly what I want when
I want to do it and I want as much of what I
want immediately when I want to you know I believe that.
That's a desired goal is. If I have any impulse at all and I want to gratified.
Ideally I would like it gratified as quickly as possible and in as great an abundance.
As I can wish for material things anything at all and in whatever it is that
I want I want immediately and I want plenty of it. Do you get it.
No not all the time. Certainly not. And you know and it's unfortunate but I I
and when I don't get it I get frustrated and
angry and upset but I would like
to what do you think you want to go from here. What are you doing. Your next of X. and I'm Which long are you
satisfied with this. I'll tell
you I always wanted to really do is much as I could as long as it
was comedy in any area. I do like the idea of writing essays writing
funny short stories writing movies directing movies directing Broadway writing for Broadway writing for
television appearing on television directing on television you know as long as it is
somebody all those kind of projects interest me. The only things that don't interest
me are projects of a more serious nature when I say serious that's a bad
word more dramatic nature. I don't want to get involved in anything
that isn't funny because I'm not good at it and then I'm not good at
something I flounder around and that causes a lot of unhappiness. So
and also I don't want
to say anything in my work but securely. I'm not
looking in any way at all. To make any.
Statement or any sort of pedantic or even month a day and take
message of any sort I just want to make the people laugh for the time
that they're at the play that I write or watching my act and that's all
I'm not interested in if
there happens to be. A message in there
fine but you
know it really doesn't interest me very
much you know series of why there's such inordinate reporter between you and the audience.
No I don't think one ever really knows what it is that the
audience is getting out of him when he performs it was always a mystery to
me why anyone like me I don't mean that self-effacing me.
I
mean you know I knew I was telling good jokes and I know that I was able to deliver them decently I
wasn't stuttering and stammering I knew to face the audience
but I didn't anticipate that there would
be a particular report I didn't think that I would be chosen out
of fifty comedians say to to advance beyond
the other forty nine. I mean that you know I'm giving
a hypothetical thing here. So I don't really know I walked out on stage
and and get ready to do my act and I guess it's occurred to me at times that I
don't present any threat to
them that they you know
that what's not to like about me you know I mean I'm I mean I'm obviously not
going to hurt them in any way and I think I'm not going to take their women and
I'm not going to steal their money or involve any of them
in intellectual discourse that's beyond them or anything I'm just gonna come out and tell
a couple of
jokes and I don't dress better than they do and I don't do this deliberately mind you
but apparently they don't find anything in me that they
feel competition with I'm guess I'm I'm no contest to them so it's
a joke and even then incidentally if the jokes aren't funny.
We had like to close with an excerpt from your new record modestly entitled.
Woody Allen not so modest when you see the picture and I want to thank you very much for this interview.
Thank you.
I went to N.Y.U. myself I would say. A solo major that.
I took all the
abstract philosophy courses in college like truth and beauty and its vast
truth and its immediate true. Introduction
to go to death. One o one in
the
post not a big way my freshman year. I cheated on my metaphysics finals. Alison I
looked within the soul of the boy sitting next to
me
and my mother who is a really sensitive one and when I started college she locked herself in
the bathroom took an overdose of March on
time
and I was analysis should I know that. I was in group analysis when I
was younger so I could afford private. I
was kept in the late. Paranoid
softball
team to play old in the Roddick's on Sunday
one male bias against the bad
weather
and if you don't seem to write explain stuff on it's really funny feels like I'm
very I'm feeling guilty and go
back
the
you. Also I have a cousin that my parents made that really strike
me as a boy because I went from four years of college and became a
mutual fund salesman and he married a VERY SOON girl from the neighborhood her know
was lifted by a golf pro. Hit.
Hooked up overhead.
They moved to the suburbs unable kinds of status symbols of their own home
and station wagon and fire insurance
and. Life insurance and mutual funds
and I don't know what else to tell you about myself. I was a writer
and an actor the television idea was not an act it was an
acting class we did a play in acting class by Paddy Chayefsky called getting
in and I play the part of God and getting in.
Was typecasting.
Nose method acting so two weeks before I started to live the part off stage. I
really came and got the blue suit. It took
taxi cabs all over New
York. It took big.
To
get into a fight with a guy and I forgave
him
to some guy hit my fender and I said on to him.
I
said Be fruitful and multiply.
But not in those words.